oh wow he put up a fight hey what's up
guys I hope you had a great summer and
enjoyed your Halloween for my birthday
this summer I got a new jet ski and
decided to take it out for some fun on
the Great South Bay with a supercharged
1800 cc engine and 250 horsepower the
zero to 60 time is around 3.5 seconds
I recorded my experience using my new
GoPro Hero 7 waterproof camera that I
had a head mount for and I figured I
would share it with you guys I have some
other ideas for videos that I'm working
on and I'm going to talk about at the
end of the video so be sure to watch the
whole thing so let's go catch some fish
and clams on a jet ski
[Music]
[Music]
I made a short stop at a small island I
call seagull Island just to capture some
videos of the scenery and Wildlife and
was careful not to disturb them too much
then I headed to the bridge which serves
as a great fishing spot because of the
underwater plants at its base I'm using
this gulp stuff which actually is really
good these fish like literally can't
resist it put it into the mouth like
this stick it in I'm gonna turn the fish
sideways like that and then put it out
through the side of the stomach like
that and then slide it on when they bite
the fish they're kind of forced to bite
on the hook they're got to put my eye
sinker on now you're not here and lock
it back up and then we're ready to roll
occasionally I do catch a crab that is
stubborn enough to hold on to the bait
and I could get bit oh wow okay
are you kidding not gonna be still
eating wow that's a first
he's still
[Music]
the fluke I was trying to catch our
bottom feeders and they have to be 19
inches to keep so I wind up throwing the
majority back it's cute my buddy another
little baby fluke is this the same guy
no I think he's even smaller
he's like a handheld little quick hey
buddy look he doesn't fight or anything
go back to mommy and daddy
[Music]
go get your granddad
[Music]
buddy after some time I did start
cashing some bigger ones though Oh see
you later buddy a little bit too short
until I finally caught a fluke that was
over 20 inches long wow that's a nice
fluke
[Music]
I also cut a bunch of baby black sea
bass but they need to be 15 inches to
keep and you really need to go to the
ocean so no keepers this summer
[Music]
[Music]
I also caught a lot of sea Robin which
are native to these waters and have no
size requirement most people find them
undesirable but if they're big enough
sometimes I will keep the little baby
and it's actually I believe it's in
northern and very very sharp spines here
so I'm gonna let him go you caught a
grandfather see Robin he is massive we
also caught a cocktail bluefish or
snapper which also has no size
requirement and are very fun to catch
nice blue this is snapper little
cocktail blue I also call it a porky
which got away but he was too small
anyway and a couple of Blowfish which we
decided to let go of course her fish all
right see you later buddy
you ready go back home I also took my
cousin and her boyfriend climbing for
the very first time
[Music]
you're gonna stick your foot in like
you're the tip of your toe just to make
a little indent and then you're gonna
take your heel and just kind of go back
like this back and forth like that and
just kind of walk your foot around in
the area just be careful because there
are some broken shells and stuff like
that should probably be about two inches
deep oh wow hey there you go nice nice
beautiful they're really nice we have
seven all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
we got 44 here basically I'm going to
take the clamp and you see this little
joint here applying pressure to it
pushing against the knife and just get
in there really hard you have to kind of
twist it back and forth until you feel
it going in okay once you get it in
there then you use the palm to push it
even farther really hard like that then
made my famous garlic gouda clan's with
a little oil lemon white wine garlic
butter and top with gouda cheese for a
delicious dinner I had a lot of fun in
the water over the summer so I hope you
guys enjoy the video as much as I did
making it if you did be sure to give it
a thumbs up down below I did catch
hundreds of fish so over the summer but
I only kept it very small percentile you
only keep them if I'm going to eat them
and if they're the proper size I have
some ideas for some videos that I'd like
to make soon one of them is a new paper
popper that's kind of similar to the
other one except it's easier in my
opinion to actually get to puff and it
doubles as a stunt plane and it pops
just like this
with a few extra folds it also becomes
an awesome boomerang stunt plane oh I'm
also trying to design a new transforming
ninja star some people have requested a
new Rubik's tutorial and I've gotten
hundreds of requests for an origami
reboot too but some people have actually
done tutorials for now I will put a pole
in the video so you can let me know
which ideas you think are best but I
think the paper popper stunt plane is
easy and quick so I think that's gonna
be the next one directly thank you guys
so much for your support and I'll
definitely be seeing you soon